what happens to the children of the
Islamic state there are literally
hundreds many of them the babies of
foreign fighters all of them are now in
limbo still in Syria not knowing where
to go or if anyone wants them with few
of their government's prepared to take
them back a few weeks ago in Syria we
found a little boy from Paris at a
center to rehabilitate the children
known as the Cubs of the Caliphate he
was only nine when his father whisked
him and his two brothers away to Raqqa
the extremists power base his father's
being investigated in connection with a
batterer Klan theater attack in Paris in
2015 the terror incident was part of a
coordinated string of attacks on one
night in the French capital they
happened the same year the three
brothers were taken away by their father
to join the Caliphate the young boy is
now 13 and all alone his brothers were
killed in a bombing and he thinks his
father's dead too but his mother's alive
in Paris and he's written to her saying
how much he loves her he's desperate to
be reunited in France
he's handmade gifts for her too his
parents had split and his mother thought
the boys were going on holiday to Turkey
he begs us to take the presents to her
the first thing he tells us the very
first thing I want to do is just be with
my mother and then I'll tell her
everything everything that's happened
everything I'll tell my mom
we tracked down the young boy's mother
in Paris within seconds of seeing the
pictures of her son she was weeping we
handed over his handmade presents they'd
all taken in days to make and then she
opened the letter and listened as it was
read aloud come on how are you
what have you been doing how is my
sister mam mam well mum I promise I love
you so much
and I have never forgotten you and
inshallah we will be together awesome
mum Oh mum I remember when you me and my
sister went to McDonald's to awesome or
McDonald and then we went to the park on
a Stevie awesome
I enjoyed these times together but
inshallah we will return to these times
she's furious at her ex-husband always
play play play
let's go Lee I'm really really really
angry about him taking my boys away from
me into that place it's not right she
says she's urging the French authorities
to bring her son back to the only home
he knows it's a moral conundrum facing
many more Western governments with
nationals and their offspring still in
Syria Alex Crawford Sky News Paris